now the last type of bond i'm going to
talk about is known as the metallic
bond which i think i know a little bit
about because i was the lead singer of a
metallic bond in high school i'll talk
about that in future videos
but let's just take one of our metallic
atoms here so iron is a good example
iron is maybe one of the most referred
to
metals
and so let's say we have a bunch of iron
atoms so f e
f e
f e
f e hope you can read that these are all
iron atoms and if they're just atoms by
themselves they're going to be neutral
but when they are mushed together they
will form a metallic bond make sense
because they're metals and what's
interesting about metallic bonds i'll
draw it down here is that
metals like to share their electrons
with the other metals it kind of forms
the sea of electrons so what it can look
like is
each of the irons lose an electron i'll
draw a little bit bigger so let's say
this is f e
plus so it has a positive charge
f e plus has a positive charge f e plus
these are all iron ions you can imagine
f e plus and we're imagining that they
have this positive charge because
they've all contributed an electron to
this c of electrons so you have an
electron here which has a negative
charge and electrons are not this big
but this is just so that you can see it
the electron here that has a negative
charge and so you can imagine these
positive ions are attracted to the sea
of negativity the sea of negative
electrons another way to think about it
is is that metals when they bond in
metallic bonds they will have
overlapping valence electrons and those
valence electrons are not fixed to just
one of the atoms they can move around
and this is what gives metals many of
the characteristics we associate with
metals it conducts electricity because
these electrons can move around quite
easily it makes them malleable you can
bend it easily you can imagine these
iron ions in this pudding or this sea of
electrons so you can bend it it doesn't
break well if you were to take a bar of
a salt right over here and if you were
to try to bend it it's very rigid it is
going to break
so there we have it the types of bonds
it's important to realize that you can
view it as something of a spectrum at
one end you have things like ionic bonds
where one character swipes an electron
from another character and says hey but
now we're attracted to each other
and you get something like salt
or you have covalent bonds where we
outright share electrons and then you
have things in between covalent bonds
and ionic bonds where the sharing is not
so equal and you get polar covalent
bonds and then another form i guess you
could say of extreme sharing is the
metallic bonds where you just have this
communal sea of electrons